it's very difficult right now to have a
fair cultural or political satire show
hmm because the institution that you're
working for is politically aligned right
and they won't allow you to make fun of
that institution so there's only one
other institution left right the
opposition so you have to push in that
direction and what we were basically
saying it's like we're just gonna do
like the funniest joke or even the truth
never has a party right like sometime
the truth is laughs sometimes the truth
is right that's just how it so we're
just gonna do the funniest bit we're
gonna have the most truthful take and
another reason why I watch your guys
[ __ ] is like there's ammunition in it
mmm now watch your videos like I got
some ammunition for a defund this
anybody wants to talk to me about
defunding I got a few bars I could give
to the people and I'm ready to go I
didn't research it you did all the
intellectual heavy lifting for me but
now I got it locked right you know and I
think we try to put that into pieces as
well it's like all right what is the one
thing this week that we want to talk
about it's five minutes now when you
talk to your friends about masks later
you can back well the bats don't even
work how do you know that
so yeah just works that way yeah I
wanted to ask you guys it's like a
question I been asked myself all week
but do you guys feel like especially in
the States we focus so much so much on
race and I say this because I find like
companies like Amazon like black lives
matter and all this [ __ ] and they're
they don't align themselves as if
they're very liberal and left but then
their work policies are extremely
conservative in the way they operate so
I feel like there's so many people
trying to invest in this racial
conversation you just keep away from
their own shitty behaviors Marc Marc is
interesting thing about this go but yeah
like I completely agree but also just
the fact that you have all these
corporations that are supporting this
quote/unquote revolution it's
effectively it should be an indication
that it's not gonna affect anyone's
money no it's not gonna affect anyone's
bond break that down though like why
would like if there's some sort of like
like revolution against like the 1% Iran
Occupy Wall Street thing ya know
wealthy corporation that's making a ton
of money especially off the backs of
poor people is gonna support some sort
of labor revolution it could potentially
hurt their line yeah like you're not
gonna support revolution it's like you
know take down Amazon Amazon it's not
gonna be like yeah you're right this is
like some sort of social issue that's
not gonna affect anyone's money so so
they can get on board and on top of that
if they get on board or can actually
infect it can actually improve their
money good guys you imagine a black
lives matter trying to be like you let's
[ __ ] up tax havens how fast we're not
shipping those and so for me it's like
such a focus and people don't realize if
you eliminate a lot of this wealth
problem a lot of these racial issues
will disappear as well people always
talking about like police reform and
this and that and I'm like that sounds
great I get in the short term but in the
long term if you don't fix people's
finances and their money problems these
issues will persist yeah the most
interesting thing about that Derrick
Chavan murder is the amount of diversity
in the cops that killed them that is
completely removed from a conversation
right like I knew this who's gonna
happen we even [ __ ] talked about in
the last piece they're like they will
make this a race war when this is a war
against police brutality that is
disproportionately affecting black
people hundred percent race plays a
pardon so everything don't get me wrong
right but it's not a white people black
people on the street beefing hmm this is
authority and authority abusing a
certain percentage of the population but
it's not as exciting and if you can
create a race war no that's the fun [ __ ]
yeah and it's additional races a weapon
that's that's what I think yeah you can
keep the poor people feuding over race
they're not gonna feud over the fact
that like they're not getting money the
minimum wage is [ __ ] them all right
whatever though yeah the economic issue
is they're not gonna let us war over
something they don't have the weapons
for yeah Amazon Amazon is like cool
y'all y'all war over race and yeah but I
Google are getting [ __ ] up we're not
denying that at all but this will keep
that as much as we can will protect our
money that will send out an email in
support of these black people were
getting killed because they shouldn't be
and it's not [ __ ] up our money yeah
do you don't think it's wait you don't
think it's gonna [ __ ] up their money cuz
I saw Bezos post over the weekend he's
getting emails for because they have
like black lives matter yeah they
support like them yeah when you go to
Amazon so for now
getting now he's getting emails that
people like oh I'm talking with Amazon
he knows good and goddamn well ain't
nobody canceling their Amazon go get you
[ __ ] go get you where else you won't get
it go to Walmart guess what they said my
clothes matter yeah I'm on things I'm
not positive you know what this is this
is another version of like the
environmentalist movement it's like you
know how like every actor cares about
the environment hmm
because it's the issue you can care
about and not piss anybody off that's
gonna buy a ticket to your film like
Leonardo DiCaprio is like okay I got to
be the biggest actor but I can't be this
rich and successful and [ __ ] this many
19 year olds and then not do some good
what kid what good can I do without
pissing off the population some of it
mmm polar bears done and I feel like
this they've realized the companies have
realized that this movement they're like
okay maybe we'll piss off some cops but
we can deal pissing off with 1% of the
population if we're gonna get tons of
free promo tons of free PR and we're
gonna have black people who truly
organizes a group especially when it
comes to like purchasing power mm-hmm
we're gonna have black people arrive for
us heavy rush they did the same
calculation as Nike yeah that's exactly
what's gonna say go I remember you were
like I'm gonna boycott Nike blah blah
blah their stocks are gonna drop for
supporting them no [ __ ] went right up
and I'm like Nikes the same company that
sells like overpriced sneakers to [ __ ]
I'm like it's all virtual signaling
because it benefits their bottom line
they're strategically placing themselves
to be on the right side of conflicts for
their bottom line
now you rarely make these calculations
as soon as it's unfashionable to support
black people corporations without well
unfashionable or as soon as it I guess
unfasten was also tied to their bottom
line yeah I'm saying more specifically
like if it's gonna really affect their
bottom line
like Nikes been around for a minute you
know what they're doing corporations see
color and I'm sure that is shown in
their hiring practices etc but more than
color they see green yeah where's the
green that's where I'm aligned yeah yeah
you know it's quick you know it's crazy
I'm thinking about like why didn't those
these corporations that existed like
during the [ __ ] Nazis why didn't they
rebrand
[Applause]